[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
gamespot live i'm richie
and today i'm joined by jake decker and
aaron sampson
uh jake will be on the mic with me and
aaron he will be playing with us but he
will be off mike
thanks for joining us we're gonna be
playing call of duty
black ops cold war zombies firebase z
the new map
so we're really excited to get into it
get into this if you're watching on
youtube
drop a like drop a sub if you're excited
for this and what's up to everybody on
facebook and twitter we're streaming
everywhere today
let me unmute the game audio here and i
think we are ready to go
knocked it out of the park flawless
introduction
thanks jake hope you're coming in clear
i hear you in my ear every
everything here is looking good sounding
good and i think we're ready to roll i'm
not going to be using
this pathetic shotgun let me back out of
that menu here i will be using the gallo
12.
and this map so far we've got our hands
on it for just a little aaron and i
jake this is your first match are you
excited
are you i'm excited zombies is the only
thing i haven't installed in the black
ops cold war because
i cannot stand multiplayer and i finish
the single player so all i have left is
zombies because i still play
the uh what was it firebase z was or no
dive machine was the first one man i'm
sad to hear
that you don't like the multiplayer but
you know it's not for everybody it's no
big deal we've talked a bunch about it
already
aaron is here also but he is uh he's
muted he's the uh
the other uh he's my correspondent in
the call of duty world
all right but jake i know you play a lot
correspondent
yeah this just in let's see here
okay i'm gonna stick with this class
back out to the lobby where the three of
us
are and let's get it going um firebase z
here we go
so we are let me see let's go endless
i'm checking out chat here what's up you
guys how's everyone going
nick says so i'm gonna bring with me the
ring of fire
uh i don't know what the boss is like
but from experience from the first one
if you don't have ring of fire
the bosses can be a pain right um if
that's a bad
idea after this one i'll switch to
healing aura okay so we can make sure
we're able to
heal easy sounds good i love healing
aura i haven't upgraded everything
but healing aura i think i have that
level two right now nice
i just put mine to three before we
started because you and aaron mentioned
it was pretty good and i was like okay
i'll do it
normally i'm like not the person in my
squad that uses it but we always have
one or two people who have it equipped
and then the other two people use uh
ring of fire nice it's good to have that
strategy like um
i usually play with like one person
maybe other two people but i usually go
solo so
it's nice to have strategy with with
friends here
uh yeah we're starting everyone in the
chat's like go go let's start all right
all right y'all chill we're here we're
here for you
we're gonna be streaming for 90 minutes
someone wrote cheeseburger in the chat
what up
cool okay i did drop the game audio a
little bit
um actually a lot of it because it's
very loud but
continue to let me know how the volume
levels are in the chat between me
jake and the game the shooting is so
loud in this game
look at this it's not even loading in
there it goes okay
i was like i'm playing on cutting edge
technology on the ps5
i'm on series x it's kind of cool that
is cool what a world
not only are we able to play on
different consoles but it actually
worked because uh
initially it did not oh yeah aaron and i
tried like at launch
and it was really buggy we couldn't even
get each other's voices to like come in
clearly
i gotta turn down my game audio too it's
very loud it is yeah
it is your turn now i will watch the
security
what's going on burritos dad in the chat
long time stream fan what's up man it's
good to see you
right here's quick revive yeah
here come wave two let's go
now jake i'm an og zombies fan and i
took a big break
like and didn't play a lot of zombies
for i would say the last
i think starting from black ops 3 i did
not play
black ops 3 with me okay oh wow
it was the last one until this one is
the last one i really played zombies and
i remember
the i think it was the map where you got
on a bus and went around the map and i
was like this is a little too much i
think
yeah transit uh i thought that map was
cool but it was a weird time like uh
where my friends were like falling off
of playing zombies it was pretty
terrible so i was playing that alone a
lot
let's make a deal my heart hurts and i
hate that map for that reason
now they're all playing again now though
so it's been great and now that cross
play is a thing
it's been wonderful my man part of me
kind of wants to go back to the
like uh modern warfare uh uh black ops
three
and four and see what the zombies maps
like but i don't know i really like the
the one they added here i think it's i
think it's a really smart map it's not
too big
um it's not too big it's like a good
throwback to the original
yeah it's kind of refreshed too like the
zombies story
timeline and stuff was crazy and like i
felt like i
left at like a really weird time where a
lot of stuff was developing they really
fleshed out the characters but then um i
missed all of that
but now i'm back it was kind of like a
nice refresher and they're bringing that
story kind of
they're weaseling that story back into
the cold war story so
like we'll we'll be able to catch up
this way i don't have enough money
uh is it for a door i can probably open
the door i haven't bought anything yet
oh yeah here i pinged it um
i guess no real rush to do all this i
don't have a lot of money but it's
probably good to get this easter egg
stuff
done early in the match not easter egg
but what we're doing here
uh we got to protect these uh these
little generator things from zombies
if we do this enough times i believe two
or three times then we unlock
access to the pack-a-punch machine so
all right yeah in the lower rounds it's
a lot easier to do
fireproxy on youtube chat says this map
is pretty cool i agree
so far i've played about two or three
pretty hefty rounds with aaron and it's
fun
it is good there's a lot to unlock i
know there's going to be all these
compilations of
easter eggs coming out and uh you know
they they jam-packed these maps with all
little fun stuff aside from the main
easter egg
the big one which i don't even know has
been solved yet
let's see here yes yes good
just need the other two back online and
we're in business we're in business when
we get max's back
[Music]
we already have drama here
any uh any sign where the weapon boxes i
mean i guess i could look to the sky for
that yeah
there it is a very vague description but
it's uh over there
let's see it is near
i'm not headed that way yeah i'll follow
you actually i should get this jug
looks like our teammates are too oh no
you're already heading that way
um i forget where the jug is already i
only bought it once
i'll buy the next door here forget jug
uh where is there it is the mystery box
i love how they kept that
like even og players know can always
find the mystery box
was it upstairs what is this over here
yes is uh where is uh oh watch out
richie
thank you thank you is where is uh
juggernog
it was outside over here you have to
follow me i think it was uh
like in the opposite direction of where
we're going
i'll take that stun grenade heck yeah
pistol come on from the box
yeah oh hitting it again
okay uh meanwhile i'll keep looking for
jug i think i totally lost it
two pistols are you kidding me right
here
and then again if you guys are watching
my screen on stream this is the first
step to get the ray k40 or
ray k84 which is the new wonder weapon
you gotta find the blueprints
a rifle like that could get us back on
equal footing with omega group
see if you can find its part all right i
gotta find jug
if you are looking to unlock that there
are so many doors i feel like more than
normal
yeah well i mean it's a bigger map this
time so duh but
it it's accentuated when you don't know
what the hell you're doing because this
map is
all very new to us all right
this is powered on we got to protect
these bad boys sounds
oh good way behind i'm coming i never
found jug i got
i'm sorry it's okay i guess what i
should have said is oh yeah i used it
but i can't say that i found it
i used it the last match
okay
jake what's the highest level in d
machina that you've made it to
uh my friends and i made it to around
46. we probably could have kept going
but it was like 2 a.m
oh god yeah 46 is great though man
did you like x fill or die
uh we just we we x filled um but once
you uh
like figure out routes for everyone to
run circles around it's pretty easy
yeah just like uh yeah any classic
zombies map same thing there's always a
there's a great path oh juggernog's here
by the way there's a great path
um later on in this map uh i know it's
up
see oh yeah we have a compass up top
it's in the northeast direction there's
a great little circle place to just
circle around i was going solos earlier
and i was just slaying him
what's the furthest you got in die
machine um
it was with aaron i don't know it wasn't
it wasn't that far um
i would say like it is the 20s maybe
like
nothing crazy
i have i have two very good friends who
are
obsessed with zombies nice they're
brothers
and they have made it to like wave like
like 70 80 90 100 in the older maps
oh and it takes them hours and hours an
hour so usually when i get farts because
i'm with them
yeah oh god the world record for those
maps is like
it is it's like it's ridiculous it's
hours sometimes some of them have like a
counter
yeah it doesn't surprise me it takes so
long
yeah especially because they get
stronger
okay here we go we are protecting these
things while
while this breaks into i think it breaks
into like a few pieces that's what
uh needs to be accomplished here
rampage hack says yeah we were right
next to jug we got it though
uh soon jake you're gonna start seeing
these new creepy monsters
with like is it the mimics or something
else yeah i think they are the mimics
they're like not the
super like high level boss ones but
they're they're big
because we killed one mimic just the
same we did
oh maybe i can maybe i wasn't around oh
is it this there it is yeah
yeah we killed one of them
mimic
got to reload this thing terrible
decision now i'm cornered
i'm surprised i survived that damn fool
over here
all right max ammo time great thing
about current max ammo is that it
reloads your gun for you
so that you don't have to uh rush to
reload
yeah i love that boss fight starts at 31
says jesus ortiz in the chat
appreciate you looking out for that oh
man 31 that sounds kind of high well i
mean if it's a really big boss
so be it you should use i'm going to try
the box again
maybe there's a chance we get the new
now i don't think we can get the new gun
this way
i should have kept the m16 whatever okay
now that we've activated these generator
thingamajigs
we can take the teleporter back to the
vietnam part of the map
and pack a punch our guns once we get
enough money
that's about as far as i've made it so
far also i should say for the chat
marcus says the hellhounds have scary
sounds now yeah
they're uh they're like the nova six
crawlers and dogs put together they're
they're nasty dude
and yeah they sound disgusting
we are all we'll split up here
okay the next piece of the ray k84 is
somewhere back here aaron showed it to
me earlier
he pinged this location um
i think i'm blocked off or i might be in
the wrong area altogether
oh he pinged it just now look at this
map okay
well got the teddy bear oh no
that's okay that was a weird spot for
the box anyway
where how do i get to where aaron is
me alone follow aaron aaron seems to
know what he's doing
yeah he uh watched a super helpful video
this morning
i'm running around like a madman and of
course you guys are looking at my screen
this is embarrassing
just kidding oh yeah this is the area
this is a great area
you're watching to do your roundabouts
with zombies okay aaron ping the next
piece i'm gonna go to him
okay how do we get there from here here
we go
almost there guys nice you guys
collected that piece
let's move on hopefully aaron knows
where the next piece is
he's he's on a path he's on a path too
excellent
uh the first piece the second step of
the
ray k84 is pulling an eyeball out of
this guy's head
hey look i can do it oh i can't watch
ew check it out oh
i mean this might not be for the ray k84
but um it's for something
and it's that's awesome
[Applause]
got him but i lost my knife oh well
retrieve i get me out of here
all right i'm gonna go to you guys
hey you're here jake yep here's the box
if you need to use
the box that's what i'm waiting for i
need 50 more though yeah i have the type
63 i shouldn't have given away
my m16 oh yeah it was worth the wait
i think i took your m16 oh cool oh
here we go this will help okay i need to
buy
i need to load up on some perks make
some money i am broke
uh we did lose aaron though let's see
he's on a path i want to be with him
oh i don't want to leave you behind
though jake uh
i will follow you okay
someone in the chat says this is an
easter egg not or this is a side quest
not the easter egg okay for sure
understood anything we're just
day one you know day zero we're just
learning all about this
okay aaron is suggesting we teleport
let's go
carpenter
i don't have nearly enough money to pack
a punch the machine but
i guess we can make money here
someone in the chat straight up said
start shooting so this is for you
brother
now he's going to be like start shooting
better
never please him
oh yeah there's a frag here
oh this is a pack punch machine yeah
once we all that
generator stuff that we were protecting
as soon as we turned all of those on
we were able to uh get the pack-a-punch
machine going that's what that was for
nice
oh there's a place to upgrade here
ew this dude was ugh
do we have a where's our fourth i guess
he's in the other dimension
jake i've been going back and playing um
all the
you know for upcoming videos i always
have to go back and play other call of
duty's
and um this kind of reminds me of
another map from um
this is ripped right straight out of the
cold war campaign for sure but
this also reminds me of another like
black ops one map
um not multiplayer like a story driven
map
see which one it is though
uh oh uh oh uh-oh what i'm gonna mimic
by myself
no where are you i'm going i'm gonna
come to you oh someone's
aaron's here with me did you guys
teleport i teleported oh no because i
need better weapons
okay i'm back alone in the village
that's okay though
there's one thing i can do i might not
be able to solve all of these damn
easter eggs but if there's one thing i
can do in zombies is survive because i'm
let's say i'm classically trained yeah i
know
and now that you can slide it's so fun
it's like just go right around them
well it's nice to have the village to
myself at least because uh the zombies
are only going after me so they're not
like splitting up
but when aaron starts pinging stuff or
you know i'll get back to the teleport
machine soon there i just want to make
some money right now
green weapons
a nuke all right
i'm gonna reload here i've had the worst
luck with this box
oh you oh yeah you are zombie slayer in
the chat says you might want to get your
hands on the napalm strike or the
artillery
they're very useful uh
then okay well i did see where that is
it was kind of near the
whole eyeball zombie scene that's where
you can like pick up a napalm strike
i'm gonna try to make some money don't
pack a punch this gun before i
go on
what i need to do i just need a good
weapon to do that with oh this guy's
armored
there it is a blue lmg i'll take it
nice and i'm surrounded okay
i'll keep killing good one
got him full fire sale
let's go find the nearest box is there
even a box in the village
yes there's one it's right here
man i have two really good guns though
but if i can get a ray gun trapped oh no
i got greedy i went for the box i
shouldn't have it's a fire sale it's
understandable
oh man i'm picking that up oh no jake
you're in the other dimension and down
it's okay aaron's near me okay cool
come on is the fire sale over yes uh
oh well hey i can buy quick revive while
i'm here and now i have enough money to
pack a punch
my first probably the gallow 12. yeah i
should be doing that for sure
oh geez what stupid step almost screwed
me up
all right i'm heading back to the other
dimension okay
okay although actually i probably should
get
juggernog first oh you didn't get it i
think that's like all i
i did but then i got downed oh that's
right that's right
okay
let's just expel and call the stream you
guys i'm just kidding
three thousand bucks i almost have
enough for quick revive
okay ooh
aaron um started the trial if we can if
we can remain
inside the location as long as possible
hmm
trial all right i'll try to run over
there they're a good way to make a quick
buck
but i never i never do them how about
you jake i
usually don't do them either like that's
a part of the machina that that part of
the lab i never even go into
i know it's just like i run past it to
get to where i need to go
yeah either right or left down that
corridor there
okay i have enough for quick revive
might as well get it oh i did not remain
inside though oh well
how's everyone doing on chat today we
are all across the internet we're on
twitter we're on facebook what's up
youtube of course how's everyone doing
it's hard
it's harder to check chat during a
zombies match
so uh yeah if i'm not saying what's up
so much
what is that check chat jason is in the
chat what up
oh bang there we go
the gala 12 is still so good i don't i
don't remember if they nerfed it
uh within zombies the ray gun got nerfed
like the first week remember that
i do it's i feel like it's so much
harder to get the ray gun though
in this than it used to be yeah i think
because there's tiered weapons now so
like
there's just so many different weapons
you can get that
i don't know i feel like i've only
gotten the reagan like two or three
times and usually when i get it it's
when we're at like wave 50 and we're
just like all right
let's just make sure everyone has a
fully upgraded ray gun
i was grinding out those uh those
crystals and um
i i just kept x filling so i can get
crystals you know
every match and uh it was like level 10
the prepare to x fill i hit the box and
then i got
the raid gun i was like what i have to
go like i had to go back to work or
something
okay for our viewers i think i should
leave the village i've been here long
enough thank you for tuning in by the
way
this map is huge and we should see more
of it i'm kind of just circling
your spot i'm gonna hang out in the
village now you should it's really it's
maybe it's very safe
what do you do do you just run circles
around that planner in the center yeah
the whole center is fine and
uh the building where the pack-a-punch
machine has an extra door so you can
like weave in and out of there too
tombstone soda i don't have enough
i'm gonna save these bullets and use the
m60 or the rpd
oh shoot aaron's fighting one of these
mimics
oh god i'm here i'm here
okay right now i should switch to this
oh here's the nuke that might help there
we go excellent
ethan in the chat says i haven't watched
videos in so long what kind of videos
let's see here no ma'am i tried playing
warzone the other day and i kept getting
lobbies with hackers
dude warzone
really hot right now with terms of
hackers dude it's there's it's
they've been hackers since like launch
but i feel like it's
there's always like a hack of the week
like the stem glitch was back
aimbot cronus max net duma routers it's
always something you know
what bums me out is that because i play
on xbox i can't opt to only play warzone
with xbox players
that's ridiculous when i heard that i
didn't believe you
yes so i run into hackers probably more
than i would if i played on
ps4 and also like i feel like people are
better on pc
typically yeah they've got you know the
mouse keyboard advantage aaron gave me
something by the way he just dropped um
a piece of intel so thank you aaron
aaron is uh
he is a video producer here at gamespot
you know
me and him do a bunch of call of duty
videos but currently he is muted he's
got
uh uh the kids in school right now you
know quarantined dad life
and now he's pinging this area aaron is
on it
oh no go over there too prove you are me
this looks like an eye test
oh and i used the zombies eyeball that's
funny
wait now what says i saw something now i
have a key
aaron thank you man aaron is just
getting us through
the side quests here
yeah oh yeah i forgot we have a fourth
uh we're playing with the random fourth
um who i don't know
who they are but he's stolen he's doing
his own
he's hole in his own is what i mean it's
good
okay i need to re-strategize what i want
to do i have enough for more perks so i
think i'm gonna
see what perk i could pick up next here
i wanna be jeez
i almost got cornered i also need armor
upgrades and going crazy
you need to hit this and take out all
these wolves right here right now
why am i green oh
i almost got killed that was a really
dumb move
yep two mimics are chasing me
and i'm just running for my life i'm
fighting for my [ __ ] life
oh
did everyone go to the okay i'm in a
corner
oh of course right when i buy ammo find
ammo
i stuck a zombie with a grenade and i
got 69 points which is pretty cool
yay me yay adulthood hey
that was ammo that freaked me out pb and
jelly in the chat says noob
thanks brother appreciate you being here
a couple a couple of noobs everyone's a
noob on this map today man
oh maybe maybe he's just criticizing my
gameplay whatever man
like jake like you said can't please
them all
people make fun of me remember um i
think in one of the call of duty videos
like the broken weapons one for using
like that blurred gameplay look i was
like what you guys
care enough and want to turn that off
like what the [ __ ]
i don't know it's just a it didn't
matter to me i mean if it really affects
your gameplay you
think it'll change the way you play sure
but like i turned it off and i was like
there's no difference here
yad ramos in the chat asks is this worth
playing
yes um well it depends you know if you
if you don't have this game and you just
want to play zombies
this is going to get a lot of zombie
support for the next you know
year um so it's worth jumping into the
journey
but if you don't like you know call of
duty multiplayer or anything like that
or you don't care about the story
maybe it's not for you or maybe wait for
a sale
i am catching up with you guys i finally
have a pack of punched weapon
feel a little bit better i've got
juggernog i probably need quick revive
but
i've got it if you're i need armor um
they don't drop
armor nearly as often because i don't
have like
uh what's called i should just go buy
armor
assault wave incoming so what what does
this mean is this another
challenge yeah i'm not sure uh but let's
stick together i'm following aaron right
here
as long as we're not in a corner
yep ray is confirming that i am a noob
that i use blurred vision
uh uh i just don't care
i don't even know what blurred vision is
it's uh in modern warfare when
and in this game when you like turn or
fire your weapon you get a blur effect
you know just like cosmetic
oh like motion blur yeah motion blur but
people
turn it off uh for whatever reason
apparently
if you don't you're a noob so good
looking out i guess
okay tombstone soda let's go i'll get
this i have enough
oh i gotta get over to that point all
right what is tombstone so to do
let's see here the official description
oh it went away it was like um
oh geez
you know what i totally blanked i read
it and i was like good that sounds good
but i just
repair your armor yes you can okay i did
just now appreciate you looking out
now it's at level two oh no i gotta go
see the boys they're all
okay let me move over here
saving our buddy okay cool i'm on my way
oh it was aaron i think
oh wow something just exploded yeah
that's the napalm strike you can buy i
think you can i don't know if you can
craft it
but you can um buy it in a different
location on
oh aaron's got the brain bot mod nice
i love the sky the effect in this map
they're definitely starting to
like make things crazy in terms of the
storyline again
daniel on the map says please show off
the map i haven't seen it yet uh
we're holding it down here for this like
wave based
round but we will you'll definitely
start to see it this map is huge and
there's a lot to
explore so stick it uh stick around with
us here
level 15. nice
and we got the max ammo okay cool
i gotta find quick revive oh that was um
in the village
okay i think i know that
yikes
there we go
don't need ammo yet
double points though
oh behind me
there we go this game is so nice it's
always like when you
especially in multiplayer when you get
like oh we got a boss thing it looks
like the terminator
what the i see you i got a ring of fire
he's done
okay that's why i love ring of fire
yeah you just put that dude i didn't
even get to see him
the terminator huh what do you look like
it it looked like
it
oh tombstone thank you daniel in the
chat says uh the tombstone perk that i
mindlessly picked up lets you keep your
weapons after
you're down so like if you if you're
down and you die you come back in the
next match i assume you have your
weapons still
oh does it keep your perks that's what
i'd be curious ooh daniel in the chat
help us out brother
um yeah find this quick revive
i'll just go to isn't there that
soda or perk machine at the beginning of
the map that has everything
yeah you can buy it there or um
in the village like it's tucked away in
a little corner are you in the village
oh like the village you started yeah oh
i remember i saw it
here's where you buy the napalm strike
but it's not available and i don't need
it right now
well i mean it'd be nice to have in my
back pocket but i guess you can't it
doesn't work like that here
[ __ ] there we go give me that armor
okay i have enough to craft some i have
enough money
there's a fire sale okay things are
looking up where's the nearest box
because there's a fire sale ah
let's go raygun i will accept no
setting yourself up less disappointment
yeah oh and i got a the magnum no thanks
at least it was a fire sale gunner hell
yeah
one just fell on the ground uh it was in
a box
nice i'm not even that it is
handy one more uh i went back to 9.50
well i have enough to try again but
i should go to a bench and build some
things too because i i could build a
chopper gunner at this point i'm sure of
it let me see here
or you know at least some other goodies
where's the nearest bench did i run
right past one i'm sure i did
ping a bench if you see one jake um
uh i think there's one near where i am
actually
oh yeah okay i can't build as much as i
thought yet but i can build
a cruise missile which is funny you know
buy a napalm strike
hmm yeah i'll try out the napalm strike
why not why not
but you lose the tombstone perk once it
once you die okay thank you chad
appreciate you guys
all is quiet here let's see let's see if
we can dig around some more i haven't
opened this yet is that even
openable nope
i'm hearing some creepy ass zombies in
the background
oh aaron pointed out a big bad dude
right here is
i think it's another oh man that may
have been what i saw
i don't have my ability so i can't shred
it again
but i do have a pack of punch heavy so
there we go
nice aaron just handled it uncharged
power cells
they look ideal for the ethereum
okay okay so we need to find a way to
charge this
oh i should upgrade my armor too or at
least uh fix it
repair your armor
okay do we want to
no i don't want a radio for x-fil
what is that music
okay thank you tony in the chat got
rushed by a mimik killed it another
terminator thing
over here though oh jeez okay um i'll
make my way to you i have some of those
decoy grenades that can
get the zombies off your back what the
hell was that
i'll be right there this weird orb just
showed up on my screen for a second
i think something was like fading out
strange use the key
the key area the key that aaron gave me
opens this locker
but when i opened it nothing happened
all right i am using a chopper gunner
okay sorry you guys are like drowning
over there i'm going my way back
terminator dude okay i got eyes on
everyone let's see here why am i using
this gun i have this there's the
terminator guy
yeah i think i killed him
how does it work jake i never i bought a
chopper gunner once but i died and i
didn't use it
um are you so safe when you use it
zombies stop aggroing you
oh that's awesome so you kind of screw
over your teammates a little bit
but like if you're surrounded and you're
about to die if you pop that thing the
zombies will
leave you alone and then you get a
chopper gunner for a long time and it
just shreds enemies
that's later waves i always do a chopper
gunner with me
um in fact i should probably try to get
another one
i'll buy one next time too i wasted some
money on napalm strike but
um not wasted but you know use some
money
yikes i think my next move should be to
try to pack a punch this thing a second
time
is it 30 000 bucks
the health bar all right there is a lot
of special infected so i am going to
throw down ring of fire if you want to
get over to me
okay oh no aaron's down i'm gonna throw
it down by the teleporter
right here i'm just gonna lay this yikes
aaron have quick revive
let's get the hell out of here
all right okay now we're already in
survival mode here this is
nuts
get away from me oh
oh okay terminator dude
there we go
thank you guys for hanging out in the
chat and stuff oh god of mimic
i mention it's a little tougher to check
on the chat but i appreciate you guys
being here and i'm looking i'm looking
this terminator guy always keeps coming
to me oh me and aaron oh
and a mimic aaron run for your life i
got a mimic behind me
okay two mimics down
another mimic they really are just uh
like from prey i don't know if you
played prey but like
they kind of look like it with like the
weird tendrils that's funny they
disguise as
uh like equipment on the ground i think
that's what aaron or
uh eric said one of them was like yeah
it's like it's just like them
weapons lab oh a mimic just spawned
right in my face i'm trying to read the
chat
okay what i did see in the chat though
was weapons lab
i'm getting we're getting yelled at to
go to the weapons lab
well i'm just trying to survive yeah but
uh i would like to explore that option a
little later
wait do i have enough to finally upgrade
what's that
i saw a prompt on the screen just a
second ago
charge the power cell there we go i run
to you guys because i got two mimics
behind me
and i've got no ammo oh shoot okay pick
up the power cell
need a little longer before it's charged
ooh you see that
there we go is this the weapons live you
guys were talking about
aaron's shredding them okay i'm on my
way over
oh never mind yeah y'all handled it i
knew you could
see look look at this i pinged this
table and that's where
um one of the big terminator guys
dropped this um
this magazine and it needed to be
charged so it's charging here at the
table but i can't pick it up now because
i got a prompt to just wait basically
okay my newest goal is to get to 30 000
uh zombie bucks to upgrade this thing a
second time
it's already losing its luster yeah i
still have
i'm still using a level one pack a punch
and it uh me too
not exactly cutting it it's it's yeah
maybe oh shoot is it 30 000 i think it's
15 000 for the second one though really
okay then i have enough
yeah i'm gonna go to the teleporter if i
can make it
and uh upgrade
oh no who's down aaron
i'm coming for aaron i'll follow you
oh he is uh not in a great spot yeah he
is out there
not in a great spot at all but that's
okay
we got this reinforcements are on the
way i got you covered
oh revive come on game
did it work okay good yep he's back
we're good
whew
okay i gotta get out of this room oh god
and see if i can teleport back to the
village because i'm gonna peck and punch
this thing again
hey this weapon lab is scary it's just
like so
tight yeah
okay i'm not going to buy speed coal i'd
rather pack a punch and i don't think i
have enough for both
at the moment
perfect
so far i'm really digging this map
uh i can't wait till like the easter egg
will be solved in no time
so i can't wait to do it myself did i
get the eye tony
yes i did get the eye we put it in the
retinal scanner and we got the
i don't even remember what we got from
it but yes we did do the whole eye thing
and then we went to the computer
okay pack a punch volume two let's go
it worked okay jake it was 15k not 30k
i think 30k is is to pack a punch it
again
okay i'm getting beat up in the village
should not be here
i'm getting jumped oh no i don't have a
decoy
i'm hanging shopper gunner
say goodbye to this little village
oh no i can't see him from this angle
one two three
there we go here comes jake
insta kill two killed two that's
oh well whatever make quick work of
these goons
oh no the terminator's here you can't
come to the village
nevermind he's dead thanks to my pack
the punched gun oh and i'm dead thanks
to me being an
idiot damn it still insta kill somebody
help me
yes thank you thank you thank you
uh what did i lose i lost tombstone okay
you live with that that's okay [ __ ]
like if you're gonna lose one might be
the one you lose
agreed yes
man okay this new pack-a-punch thing is
pulling its weight
great job gun i'm very close i need
about 900 more
okay cool i wish i could drop you money
that's one that's one thing in the cup
in the zombies community that's just
like a thing like i still
after all these years i can't just give
you money
right address especially with like
warzone too
that oh my god it'd be nice if there was
like a little
menu it would there's yeah there's only
the one where we can drop your gun and
stuff
all right i got another mimic out in the
courtyard and terminator to your right
excuse me mangler i'm way too far to be
using this uh oh
why am i using the rpd this is a mess
and i think we need to reevaluate
the village oh i got ring of fire if you
want to come over to me okay
sweet that's cool that helps players are
your
friends
yeah see look that just like destroys
bosses
it does
can we not make jokes right now my
player was like making all these jokes
yes someone got a nuke goodness
all right upgrading to level three armor
a lot of people here is
dangerous yeah that's why i was like we
should re-strategize our village yeah
i'm getting out of here once i uh
i'll leave now why don't i uh once i get
my armor let's get the f out of here
actually
i'd rather have a shopper gunner if i
can get it all right god i'm leaving
oh you're leaving not before me
and then i will follow brandon hernandez
in the chat what's up man it's good to
see you
streaming some call of duty you know it
you know
that's all i stream here i love it like
the last time i think we streamed as
game spot it was
when uh cold war might be dead nope no i
almost made it
are you in the village still yeah aaron
aaron is uh running for me okay okay
i don't want to i don't want to add any
more chaos to that equation so i'm going
to stay here it's actually quiet
in firebase aaron's going to go down too
no oh no
he made it he was like having trouble it
looked like
it wouldn't let him heal me ugh
he like stunned them all and then was oh
he he's leaving
he's out oh oh no wait now you're down
too okay let me see if i can
i should have i should have showed up
sooner i'm a terrible teammate
dartboard oh he got me
oh you got revived okay cool yep you got
me i'm getting out of here
this game mode is it's fine
all right i'm getting the hell out of
the village again looks like aaron is
too
the village is not safe not for more
than one person i don't think
yeah tony tony is yelling dartboard in
the chat you got to help me out i need
more
more information where's where is this
dartboard what does it do i know you
want to help
help me help you help me with that
comment
please tony
oh i haven't used one of these yet uh
should i for 500 bucks
i don't think i should have well
that was cool though it reminded me of
uh ascension well
ascension had those launch pads they
weren't launch pads they were like
little hovercraft things
hmm dartboard
oh no someone's down
our fourth
what are these zombies doing hanging out
oh no we got another terminator i do
have a healing aura i haven't found
i haven't been in such a pinch yet to
where i needed it i guess
um i'm always really picky about when i
use the healing aura
oh oh no
now might be a time for you viewer
oh that green pulse is healing aura home
yeah
it does like healing splash damage i
should be able to heal you i think if
you're close
i think oh no oh
healing aura okay weapons room
dartboard that's what you guys are
trying to say okay thank you thank you
that'd be cool
i don't know how you guys got on all
this intel so fast but
i'm happy you're here to uh share them
okay this is not the weapons room
i need jug immediately um yeah that's
the first thing i did
after i got up
did not waste a second yeah it was over
here
you can't you run
anymore um i think i can revive
people with the healing aura if it's
maxed out to level three but mine is
only
level two right now and that's not even
confirmed information i'm not sure if i
can do that
chat um someone's down where is he
it's our fourth i'm near him i'm gonna
try to get him but there's a couple
bosses here all right now i'm going to
try to listen
man there is the revive is so picky at
where i have to be
yeah i've had trouble with it too
um i need to find the weapons room
according to chat and find that
dartboard let's see what's up
so i'm currently in the military command
not the weapons room what's this this
collected some intel for sure okay make
some money here
weaver is speaking hey this is uh aaron
here sorry i'll sneak in real quick my
kids are
a little bit off school for them so uh
richie you gotta come over here
and you hit this computer and the
computer corresponds to like the numbers
on a dartboard i think it was like 11 10
11.
oh i gotta go back to the village and
there's a dartboard and you shoot the
corresponding
numbers i gotta go back maybe chad can
help us out after that point i gotta go
back and look at what you do after that
point
okay aaron it's good to have you back
man
probably get back off mike unless you
guys want to sit in elementary school
for sure no problem appreciate the
update though um tony in the chat says
watch for the dartboard pattern go
to the pack and punch turn left and the
dartboard in the
in the three number sequence okay so the
dartboard has a three number sequence i
think that's what aaron is
i am in village so if someone else needs
to go to village let me know so i can
first leave village okay first let's say
die
in village i'm about to do right now oh
no
you see the dartboard jake it should be
in the village
oh is it in the village well like to the
left of the pack-a-punch machine there
should be the room
and the dart board should have the a
three-number sequence i believe
that's random but only if you're only if
it's safe to do so i know the village
can always be hot
well i'm dead well you're down oh no on
the way
oh no
oh grab the charged mag but i have to
save jake okay aaron's going for jake
i'm gonna grab the mag
i don't i think i'm a lost cause aaron
i think i am too i cornered myself oh oh
oh
oh he might get to me he might get to me
he got to me
oh no he had to stop and then i died oh
i think i'm gonna die too oh no this is
getting tough i keep getting cornered
i don't know this map like all of them
yet like the rest of them
yeah clearly it seems i should hold on
to that shotgun
oh yeah never part with the gallo 12.
okay let me try to bomb one of these
guys to get a crawler going
okay got some crawlers going maybe we
can take a second here to explore calmly
and see what's up with this whole
dartboard thing by the way yeah this
isn't a stream to
to race to get to the easter egg i'm
sure it's been accomplished by now but
um
we're just having some fun streaming
first day of the new map
hopefully i can live oh got carpenter
okay
no you guys are are you guys all
watching my screen now this is
all right hold on implementing strategy
now yoink
galway here
this thing is slower i'm used to the
street sweeper i guess okay that recon
that decoy did not last very long at all
oh this is the perfect place to round
them up with the exception of these
fools
i will not be going back to the village
okay my my new goal
chat and team is to just survive to get
you guys all back
you can do it thank you thank you
wish me luck that's why we're watching
you play
hey i got down like three times already
[Music]
okay now it's time maybe to use this
little thingy here
excuse me excuse me coming through hot
stuff
i'm still getting okay
oh no oh help me
wait no there's no one okay
let's breathe is there armor here
that was stupid okay there's the thing
to buy armor in the building
okay i see this is where i died though i
got trapped behind a door with a bunch
of zombies
oh okay okay okay let me
calmly get the f out of here then
oh my god this is in higher levels the
village
is not so friendly anymore yeah it's
[ __ ] scary dude
okay i don't want anyone coming from the
left
look at the map oh my god
i hate when the pressure's on like this
the new map is free yes you have to
you have to have cold war of course but
it is uh free
dlc we love it
okay if we can find an armor guy before
it gets too hot around here what did he
drop
do that
okay just for a second
armor repaired okay
really at a time like this
the only thing i would want is a ray gun
oh my god
okay forget the fire sale shouldn't have
picked it up i need you guys back
asap
oh this is ridiculous oh i'm dead oh no
what the what
i'm almost out of bullets this is
ridiculous wait there's an ammo box
somewhere here
okay i just i swear to god i just saw it
okay doing the roundup if you play if
you've played zombies for years
you know what i'm doing need to
recuperate you need to breathe this is
ridiculous without you guys
nope definitely not using this rpd bass
rpd
but i need ammo for this i'm willing to
pay where's the ammo box
four bullets left folks
okay new priority wait is it over there
you see it
no that's the table
two three four okay we can just spray
into this
this crowd
it's been what the it's barely doing it
there it is
what i bought ammo for the wrong cut i'm
toast
wait no okay maybe i'm not toast i just
gotta shell out money again to do it
there it is got the box to myself what
up terminator
yee wait give me that no
okay
where'd that one come from
get away from me i don't corner me oh
oh no it won't be able to keep up
i'm toast
crap ola all right well folks we have a
we have shot for a uh actually let's see
we started today at 11 30.
so we got to shop for another another
round here jake if you're down we got
until one o'clock
do it let's do it because that was
okay maybe we can try to x fill two
yeah that might be a good idea like just
play that strategy if it ends up if
it ends up going past uh we're supposed
to end
that's a good idea endless and then
we'll take the xfil if needed
okay travis in the chat asks does this
work on the original xbox one yeah
yes it should this game is available for
xbox one should work just fine
rey is like i know what i'm doing i'm
sure you're making fun of me that's cool
i lost took a big l for the chat i
thought i had it
i had it but hey to be fair i never said
i know what i'm doing
did i you did better than the rest of us
what did we get to 19 20 something like
that yeah
not bad not bad why isn't it starting
did i do it i've had worse first runs
that's true that was your first run okay
what is it loading i hit endless
hmm do we need a fourth for endless i
swear it's just not letting me click
i am the party leader right oh you
should be
i thought i see a little crown next to
your name
yeah 20 round this is so strange
let me um
bring party let me back out and uh try
that again zombies
i swear i'm just pressing x and it's not
party limit changed to four you guys are
here with me
lindsay asks how do i not have the gallo
12 maxed out at this point yeah
good question i don't use it a
multiplayer i only use it in zombies
and uh apparently i plus i play less
zombies than i thought
this is goofy what's going on here hmm
jake maybe would um maybe we can join
you
in like you can be party leader i can't
seem to get it to work
sure we can try that okay let's see
lobbying party
yeah okay now invite you guys
maybe we do need a max of four
underrated asks can i join y'all i mean
we can use the fourth
um but you got to be quick because jake
is setting up the party and
well you know what it might not work out
um
let's get your are you on xbox we might
be able to get your username
and if we die quick you might be able to
join but i don't want to promise
anything because
we gotta i'm already delayed with this
whole situation
zombies accept the lobby here
joining the party
okay and then now from here jake are you
able to like
start it i had trouble with that part
looks like it
although it looks like you just got
booted richie
really it looks like on my end it says
me you and
hitman brock left the party but on the
right side where
you know the friends list is am i still
there nope
what the hell i'll send you another
invite it's goofing up it's goofing up
man
because we're doing cross play that's
what i figured it's crossfade was so gl
so good in like regular multiplayer like
i don't know why it's a problem in
zombies
connection lost to host oh no
okay i've accepted your party invite
joining party okay looks like i'm back
here
jake is such a good teammate
and jake it was kind of a uh i was happy
to find out it was a surprise
to find out that you play so much
zombies
yeah i like when the when
uh black ops first came out that's like
all i was playing
after i'd finished the story nice i did
a private one
i thought that might make it better oh i
think it worked yeah
oh error game session no longer i got
kicked too
cross play big l it's my fault
why don't you try inviting people again
because you at least were able to get us
all in a game
that's true okay let's see here there
you are
invite to party aaron just joined my
party
let's go
evan we didn't die on the fourth round
but yeah i can't imagine bro we died on
like level 20 something
okay we're all here i'm gonna try again
you can hear it in game i'm clicking the
hell out of this thing
i can't even do the 20 round not letting
you yeah
um daily challenges
does any of it work like does d machina
work i don't want to press it because
it'll start
um this is goofing up maybe you try
private
let's try that's down below here private
match firebase z
not everyone in your party has the
required content to play this map
yes we do what the we just did
maybe maybe i'll restart my game maybe
it needs to do one of those weird like
server up or uh playlist updates oh
maybe that happened to me when i was
testing zombies earlier it might be
like a hot update why don't we all do
that i think it
i think it may have been an issue on my
end okay
um looks like aaron left too we're gonna
do a quick reboot
quick uh one two how do you do and see
if it works because uh
we can't play it's like we're so close
but we can't play
i'm gonna back out of everything leave
alone
restart the old game here
let me go to the home menu just do it
like a
hard reset here close the game
refresh yeah chad is even saying refresh
refresh
there are new zombies carlos yes welcome
to the chat welcome to the stream there
is a new zombies map it launched today
called firebase z and that's what we're
playing
all right i'm back in it okay cool me
too i'm rebooting
underrated in the chat says restart the
game yep that's what we're doing right
now
thank you thank you for all the
suggestions and thanks for your patience
this is
it sucks when this happens live you know
like so appreciate you sticking around
and
hanging out that's all we want to do
okay i'm back in the menu
um how do you want to go about it jake
do you think i should try being party
leader again or do you want to go for it
why don't you try again okay i'll invite
you guys
here's jake uh
invite to party unless their game is
reloading okay and aaron will be here
momentarily
there's not going to be another one out
there um evan there should be more like
remember how black ops four had like god
ten zombies maps this is just the
beginning so if you're if you're worried
about that i wouldn't be um
this is map zombies map two and i'm sure
there's gonna be way more this year
um but so far this has been fun if
you're tuning in just now hopefully we
can get it going
yes it's looking good
don't don't jinx it no i'm gonna just
stop um
nathan says they need to remake the
originals again they did remember for
black ops
three they had the zombie chronicles
that's
that's good i had fun with that we
played in the office a little bit here
too remember that
underrated my my game hasn't been
updated says
underrated rob hey what's going on rob
do
rob dunn in the chat says hi to everyone
we are playing some
zombies by the way i don't have facebook
open but if you're watching hey what's
up
twitter also how's it going we're
streaming across all these platforms
today
um so thank you guys for being here
we got peter panda with us too so we're
in good hands peter panda
oh that's it if we're going to finish
this
there is an ending to this game and
we're going to find out
so were you just upgrading and pack a
punching the gallow richie
yeah yeah that's it
there are a lot more little boxes and
things that you accidentally can corner
yourself behind
and i gotta figure that out see all
these like crates on the ground you can
see in the background
um but i got caught up on a stupid
little box and i got cornered uh
tony aaron and jake are on xbox i'm
they have their series x uh copy of the
game and i have ps5
uh and this is how it looks no i'm just
kidding it'll load up soon but the
graphics were looking really shitty on
my screen
it's like not rendered yet
but yeah i got the ps5 copy uh and
crossplay
was working out uh until just now
when we try to you know when we try to
get together i'm not punching people i
should be meleeing in round one what am
i doing
reboot the game no no we're good we're
back in the match all three of us are
here
we have was it panda
yes you can upgrade at the table the
table is back and you can
upgrade and there's new upgrades that
have been added like the napalm strike
no no i think that's been in there
uh the cruise missile that's new
and uh the easter egg we kind of got it
going at least the side quest for the
ray k84
but you know takes time and uh
we're just here to have some fun thank
you all for joining again
whoa that dude that zombie juked me
we got a nuke already oh yeah a nice
early nuke yep
i'll take it riku yes it is out it
dropped yesterday night at 11 00
p.m pacific time um the easter egg was
not unlocked until
this morning i believe at nine pacific
standard time
so it is out across all platforms
excuse me while i caught there i had a
cough off
off the mic there neutralize that rotten
bastard
okay but yes it is live we're playing
that's not even an early build or
anything this is it this is
hot it is live
look at these peter panda is not in a
good spot
already surrounded by zombies
man he's there he goes he's using his
fists oh well
in the early rounds i guess that's
acceptable
max ammo let's go
for all the ammo i've used up
i don't know jake these guns are
registered weapons right
got another mini update
try getting dead wire ammo oh the dead
okay the dead wire ammo mod on the
shotgun it does more damage to the big
guys
good looking out nathan thank you um i
definitely gotta hit up the mod soda you
know
machine this match i don't think i did
last time i got jug
quick revive and tombstone like which i
don't think i needed
oh free uh tomahawk heck yeah
boom boom boom
all right we each have enough money to
get the ball rolling if we want to if we
want to teleport
i'm having a weird glitch where the
zombies eyes
like the glowing eyes are in front of
their face oh no
so it looks like their eyes are outside
of their head that's really weird
i guess that's better than not being
able to load into a match but yeah
is like um i see where you're coming
from if you if you want me to
exclusively melee right now i totally
get it but
max ammo is a little more generous in
this game so i'm okay with just wasting
some bullets
uh although it got me killed last time
so i might take your advice
this is for you lindsay i'm just mailing
the f out of these zombies
now it's taking too long though
okay let's get to one of these reactors
and get it get it going
let's get that pack-a-punch machine
active
and i'm broke oh well wait
who's there it's aaron
yeah wait this costs 500 bucks to turn
yeah
i'm 10 bucks short aaron can you spot me
bro
rob down in the chat says i love playing
zombies heck yeah man
this is your day then this is the new
map launch
are you enjoying it so far rob dunn have
you have you played much yet
bowie nycha's bowie knife is clutch af
that's true aaron is a fan of the bowie
knife
um he was singing in surprises yesterday
when we were playing
the street sweeper is available in
zombies you can use it i wouldn't
recommend it because it takes forever to
reload
what ah killer guns in the chat says i
got the ray-k
i don't believe you bro that's cap i'm
just kidding but i'm just jealous
wait who's down
someone down i swear i saw someone
getting down i don't think so
okay
oh they're they're all over this machine
get away oh
i gotta reload this thing too oh
insta-kill
perfect all right back to the fifths
oh they're all gone
reading chat here upgrade your healing
aura yeah i have enough crystals i think
to do it now
i don't know why it's not maxed out you
know what i normally don't play with the
healing aura i play with like the
uh the frost gun whatever i like that
one i love freezing them in place and
just taking a breath
i don't think there's any bad perk but
um
i've just been focusing on other ones to
upgrade first
what's that music jake do you hear it oh
it's a typewriter i think
maybe it's this keypad no
it's laughing too i think it's the
keypad keypad
keypad or the safe
the hell it's funny i'm gonna open this
locked door because why
not where are you oh okay
okay my next priority is to get
juggernog
i almost have enough but it's uh sitting
pretty right here and i can't have it
wait how much 3 000 uh
i thought it was like uh well i thought
it was 25.52
that's like the og price come on i'm a
vet player i'm just kidding
okay i'm gonna follow you guys settings
for us yeah
oh were you born before in uh 1990 yeah
you get a senior discount here
oh my goodness this mimic
pulled me right in i did not appreciate
that
i only have a base gallow 12.
and aaron poor aaron is here fighting
off the mimics
to try to do his trial
okay you know what i have c4 what am i
doing
oh sorry aaron i cannot help you
complete your challenge oh no i got
trapped
oh no oh no it's happening jake
i'm not oh all right
max ammo i gotta loop around
god it really does not you lose those
perks fast i think that's one thing that
i really don't like about
the newer zombies is that you lose your
perks while you're down
yeah like i'm all for losing perks if
you die but like while you're down seems
a little
a little harsh it's rude yeah it's like
it's like in your face like hey
hey nothing you can do but you're losing
your perks just saying that's what the
game is doing to you
oh yeah joseph in the chat says go prone
to any perk in the and the perk machine
itself drops a hundred bucks i forgot
about that
dude and now that i have enough for
juggernog i'm just gonna go
wait take that stun with me heck yeah
are you guys enjoying the map let me
know in the chat i mean it's only the
morning of
so we're all like a little rusty but i'm
sure people have already figured out the
damn easter egg
we are just trying to like have some fun
survive and maybe get the ray k84
let me know if you have got it already
there we go i got the loose change from
the juggernog machine just by going
prone it gives you 100 bucks
okay my next priority is to definitely
we should okay finish off these uh
juggernaut was 2500 for me
what you're getting ripped off i am god
they hate me
they're like oh yeah that guy from
gamespot no no no
what the okay now i'm broke and i can't
get to the next
ether reactor a third of the ether eat
boom wait is it open down here
am i making a fool of myself there are
other ways around
it might be open already no
okay well first order of business
business
is to get the reactors going and to get
the pack-a-punch machine
active nice
now i have enough
get away from me
hmm these are fun i'll take this over no
i need if i need a crawler i'm going to
need molotov so i'm going
oh i've got an a palm strike in a box
nice oh aaron's opening some doors okay
aaron
cleared the path excellent
tony we can uh this will probably be our
last match you've been a great help i
don't know if we'll be able to play
anymore after this one but i will add
you if you want to play some zombies it
sounds like you know what you're talking
about
so i will add you if if you want we can
play later
you've been a great help tony thank you
and to you tony in the youtube chat has
been
great hope you guys have been great
kills the mimics in seconds what does i
missed it reading chat here again
okay time to protect these thingamajigs
what are they called
that's that's our objective okay
nice that'll help phew
okay here's a mimic following for some
reason whenever my character
mantles over something he goes
sounds really weird like it sounds like
an unfinished
like sound effects that got cut early
that's weird
sometimes it sounds fine a lot of times
is it like that like imagine that cut
off like half a bit cut off
that's so weird
okay this reactor is online we should be
able to go back and
uh see that the pack-a-punch machine is
there although
i almost have enough to pack a punch
let's uh let's change that
this dude did a cool like 360 flip over
the
ledge here
okay
where's everyone else we haven't done
any part of the
ray-k easter egg yet though
i think aaron's in the area to get it
started
double points baby
okay i have enough i think i'm gonna go
pay a visit to the village
pack a punch my gallow
is the normal gun in this ray map or is
the normal ray gun in this map
asks nolan i'm not sure i assume so but
i haven't you know
i always have bad luck trying to get one
from the box
we didn't turn okay the power is not on
yet so we're not ready to do this
whoopsie daisy got one more reactor i
think one more
okay cool on the way back then or maybe
i can kind of low-key hang out here in
the village
like i have not good guns not a lot of
ammo
uh oh
no i'll go back to the other i'll go
back to firebase z to help you defend
the uh you know the generator thingies
hands and arms inside the ride at all
times let's go
oh abel in the chat says uh he had that
same problem i think
jake is talking about the sound problem
but he just reset his xbox and it works
fine
oh really yeah
you know what i need a backup i'm going
i'm hitting the box
i got another gallo 12.
sick
all right aaron i'm here to help you
defend oh
get away you pathetic zombies
there we go i feel like this will help
that's my contribution
yeah rob dunn says the ray gun is
extremely hard to get still is yeah i
forget there's a really
like pers small percentage it's like .3
or something that's
ridiculous yeah
okay now we can hey look the radio is
there for x-fil
we have eight minutes what do you say
i say we get to the next one the next x
fills
okay okay what's it every five i thought
it was
ten i might be dripping though ten all
right we'll probably just dive in
sounds good
infected threat removed
we still don't have the power on
a bunch of noobs we are who's that guy
from earlier who was like noobs yep
confirm i mean y'all don't have to stop
if you don't want to
eric the voice of god uh we'll see i
mean uh
maybe we just try to survive this round
when he's or like
when this round is over we call it what
do you think eric
the voice of god has left the building
it's up to you guys okay
um i don't want to go over way too much
you know we
it's only thursday yet we got work to do
but um this has been fun and i want to
see if we can
oh um
is the x-fil gone oh no it's still there
okay
tempting tempting well the x fill option
is going to go away soon jake
what do you think i think i think we
push on we push on okay
f the x fill we're gonna push on
oh nice one aaron he knifed that dude
and he fell off the rail all together
there we go there's our xml
hmm okay
these are still under attack oh my gosh
this one lousy zombies beating up
beating up the generator thing there we
go
now this should break into a million
pieces and the power should be on
i hear noises yep
you guys play in the chat or either of
you uh
jake do you play with your feel the
vision turned like all the way up like a
you know max zoom out i do yeah
i'm so happy that's finally a thing you
can do and uh
on console i was happy with that too
is that me my mic oh yeah someone
outside is starting their
janky ass car um i was happy to see that
too but i don't really
utilize it so much i think it like chugs
my like frame rate when i do it or i
might just be a member
that that's why before at least i think
that's why like most games before didn't
let you do that
was because it would the frame rate
would take a hit because you just have
to load more stuff in your field of view
at once
yeah that being said though i still feel
like i'm going faster
like it's so cool when i do you feel the
vision
okay chat says the gal 12 from the box
is better than the one i have so i'm
gonna upgrade this one
in the pack of punch machine good call
out chat appreciate you
richie why things are still chill let me
show you the dartboards right here oh
okay there's aaron
aaron is back in the chat oh okay there
it is
this stupid dartboard is part of the
easter egg later on
i don't know if we'll get to it but we
got close last time
okay i pack a punch this gun now my next
priority let's see
i need armor and i have quick revive
that's good
i'm just thinking of upgrades i need
kill the zombies says abdullah thank you
we will
abdul are you playing this uh do you
have call of duty zombies let me know in
the chat
abdullah responded with kill the zombies
and all caps okay
very good we are we will
check this out this is for you kill them
hey that one looks like retinol this is
the same little t-shirt oh get away from
me
tony says it's locked as far as i've
seen the the the entire easter egg
the big easter egg is it still locked
treyarch tweeted something i missed it
but they tweeted something about how
they're gonna roll out the easter egg i
totally missed it
d machina that map was fun too i think
you're right jake it's like the perfect
size
and it was like it was just a nice
refresh to the series
it was a good welcome back to og fans
and for people who you know all zombies
players
zombies
[Music]
this one though is massive i feel like i
still haven't seen all of it
yeah i i think i'm starting to get a
handle on it though yeah
and there's always intel like you got to
keep like looking around
they do that all the time like they
always try to they always put intel
and easter eggs in these zombies maps
and it's like ah so hard i want to
explore you know
unless you got a crawler going
but there's intel everywhere dude i've
accidentally found like seven pieces of
intel
whoa
maybe i should use this for now there we
go
i have two gallo 12 shotguns so i'll
save my pack of punched bullets
the first let me see maybe i'm in the
area where you uh
where you get that eyeball that's a cool
scene maybe i can show it to chad again
or for those just tuning in not this guy
right no it looks kind of looks like
this guy but
there's a zombie here you gotta pull out
his eyeball and use his eyeball for a
for like a retinal scan later it's
pretty great
it was over here i guess i'm tripping
whoops it easy
i love when the zombies are stunned
they're like just
looks like they're dancing
hey where is that zombie i totally lost
him oh well
fire sale okay i'll give it a shot
no thank you
oh jeez
kaboom
okay i should pick up some armor and i
definitely have enough for speed call i
have more than enough for speed cola
so i'm gonna show some love here and get
all of
these perks upgrade
yikes i'm not sure if it's safe to jump
i mean i assume it is it'll probably
take some damage but
yeah that was a small fall
okay that speed cola which is perfect
for the gallow 12.
a rifle like that could get us back on
equal footing with omega group
see if you can find it sounds like
someone got the blueprints for the
ray k 84 which is the first step
you will first need something from him
his body must be around here okay now i
think we can get that eyeball
jake you're in the area this is where we
get uh i think down
i'm in the eyeball area um no i thought
so maybe not
no it's not him either i think it's
where i was the the um
the part of the easter egg just wasn't
unlocked yet so i'm gonna go back to the
eyeball guy
we got panda over here holding it down
i think i've gone too far i'm not near
i'm trying to get to like that beachy
area oh here it is
hey i'm actually gonna mix behind me i'm
running
i swear was that guy i guess not oh
aaron's leading the way
oh yeah okay
i'm gonna go there he is
are not here yeah check this out chat
probably seen it all right
i gotta get this guy's eyeball
nathan says leveling up your stamina
reduces the fall damage good to know
eyeball retrieved now we got to go to
the computer
ew hey what there's all this stuff
laying around
insta kill very good i will melee my way
to the computer
okay
nice okay to the weapons lab
i think that's what it's called when i
once i get there i'll figure out i'll
check the
top left there and see what it's
actually called that one room with the
computer in it i'm at the helipad now
okay
you're doing all the heavy lifting
meanwhile i'm just staying in the center
surviving okay
let's see here's the computer retina
scanner
here we go
yep there's the eyeball getting scanned
550. it takes so long to get some of the
crap yeah
these are like atari 2600 sounds
got the locker key okay and the locker
is over here somewhere
okay
another dimensional bridge
yeah i'm looking for it actually forgot
where the locker is
oh that one that we found uh it's like a
little oh no that one's different
um i'll double i'll double check but uh
earlier i found a locker that looked a
lot like this one
uh but it said you know use the key and
unlock the door
um back let me look for
i'm not sure it doesn't sound familiar
it might be
all right heading over to the control
unit to help
okay you guys do that i'm gonna find
this damn locker i totally forgot where
it was
i wasn't even paying attention and i got
the prompt to unlock it
i think i found it okay so this is the
locker
it's right here if anyone wants to see
it for next time
it's an empty ass locker did something
drop
what did i pick up armor i think i
picked up some armor
no i am looking for here
so silly it opened a locker and chat you
all saw
nothing fell out um
maybe it's another locker that's the
thing maybe i'll find another locker
around here
a gun locker or something cool
meanwhile the the guys are doing all the
heavy lifting now i'm just looking
around
like a madman for a locker
locker do i still have a key
yes i do locker locker okay i'm in the
field hospital there's no locker here
that i found
chad if you know help me out oh you can
open all the lockers okay yeah i'm just
trying to find one
really someone got three gun oh no peter
panda got
is that i don't i don't know it's like a
shooting purple lasers is that the
what is it ray k47 or whatever no way
yeah maybe
that's the anything purple's usually oh
you know what he might have an ammo mod
on
it looks pretty cool okay whatever it is
i've opened two lockers no luck
hey you know what this might be the
perfect time jake what do you say
i'm down if we think it's time okay
i'm gonna pack a punch my knife though
then if we're gonna do this
i'm gonna double pack a punch my gallo
12 and then i think we're ready for xfil
oh nathan says the locker part is
probably not ready yet because it's
it's part of he thinks it's part of the
chopper right now
you're getting one right now what
happened someone called in one
oh [ __ ] okay
don't have enough okay i don't know what
i was thinking
all right gotta pack a punch knife
and i killed terminator in two slices oh
shoot that's sick oh pack a punch knife
killed the mimic two killed a mimic
all right this is the way to play
did anyone pick call in the x-fil i
might go teleport and do it
uh no oh no the mimic
others
oh i can't get out of here oh no the the
village is all too hot
i gotta i gotta use my shopper gunner go
for it
oh boy oh boy here we go
tony says i just passed some intel yeah
i'm sure i did there's so much around
here
okay requesting immediate expo
oh my god chopper inbound omega base
limited windows so move your ass
right i just got to get out of here
making my way wait is the the is it in
the village jake
no it doesn't seem like it okay gotta
get there now
wherever it is i just gotta juke these
zombies real quick
i think it's where do we call it in oh
it's yeah it's
kind of far oh no i'm totally down
i got cornered on a staircase
oh i'm so close well i'm in the exvil
zone but like it's it's
i'm coming tony says watch for the
dartboard pattern
and now tony man we're trying to exfil i
think i don't think we'll be dealing
with the dartboard anymore
don't worry about me it's so crazy right
now
oh snap you guys saved me
we x fill together i don't know if we're
gonna pull this off
yeah we have four seconds we're toast
one hostile left oh
yes well
we you know there's no easter egg but we
had some fun here today
jake and aaron thank you so much for
joining me and chat
all over twitter facebook youtube thank
you guys for being here
i think that was a pretty good way to
end it that was so close i thought we
were just going to lose it there
but we were as well we did we did great
thank you guys for joining us today
we'll be back with some more game spot
live at some other point
but be on the lookout for more call of
duty stuff
and subscribe to the youtube channel if
you haven't already we got a lot of
stuff out already
a lot of good call of duty stuff a lot
of hitman stuff
any game we got you covered thank you
all for watching
we'll see you next time bye jake